Speaker 1: Mike Pompeo is making pretty
clear that he wants to run for president
against Donald Trump. And it's interesting
to keep an eye on who's kind of considering
a challenge to Trump within the Republican
Party. Mike Pompeo was the secretary of state
under Donald Trump. Here is a moment from Fox
News where he didn't even try to conceal the
fact that, yes, he's planning on running.
Speaker 3: Process is kind of lay that out.
People get a chance to say, whoa, this this is
huge. So there is a educational element that
is important as well. In the end, you got
to pay your bills. I am confident that the
United States government will do so. I only worry
that we will not begin to change the trajectory
of the American economy by growing it and the
American and American spending by reducing it.
Speaker 4: In the meantime, you're
running for president, are you?
Speaker 3: Socotra. Neil. Yeah, nice try. Yeah, I
like that. I like that. Little passive aggressive.
Perfect. Yeah, but we're doing all the things that
one would do to get to get ready, but we're, we're
still trying to figure out what we're doing.
Speaker 1: All of the things that one would do
to get ready. Well, that's pretty clear.
Speaker 3: We don't have
anything to announce today.
Speaker 4: And would it be impacted
at all by Donald Trump? I mean, he is running
he's the only announced candidate. You know,
you worked with him and obviously he has said
of Ron DeSantis, of course, if he runs it, it's,
to paraphrase it, a little disloyal. He's
done a lot for them. Do you feel that way?
Speaker 3: Oh, goodness. Now I was incredibly
loyal to America and to the work that President
Trump wanted done. The American people will
decide who the next Republican nominee is,
and anybody who throws their hat in the ring has
the responsibility to go out, compete, make their
case, make the arguments to the people of Iowa,
New Hampshire and South Carolina. All right. About
the American people sort through who they think.
Speaker 1: Usually even right before someone
announces, they still do. I'm not thinking
about 2024 and he's going, yeah, so we're
doing everything to prepare, but I don't have
an announcement right now. Okay, cool. So you're
running and we're waiting on announcement. But
what's interesting is Mike Pompeo for a while now
has been making clear that he wants to run. And
this whole time I haven't understood why he thinks
that he's likely to do well. I just don't see him
as someone who could carry a lot of support within
the Republican Party because you either have to
be a Trumpster, which Trump feels right because
he's running or a really kind of on the fence
Trumpster. Here's what I mean. And it's kind
of just DeSantis is the only person who fits this
mold. If you're going to do well in the Republican
primary, all of these individuals I wish would
not be president, but within this context.
DeSantis appeals to the radicals and appeals
more radical than even Trump sometimes with
his vaccine comments and also appeals to more
moderate Republicans because he comes off less
erratic like Trump does. And so he's a little
bit more of an official politician type, esthetic
type vibe. And people are freaked by that. And
they think that Ron DeSantis is a more moderate
Republican and would be fine. And so DeSantis
feels that Mike Pompeo is making clear he's not
trying to be a Trumpster, but his claim to fame
is being secretary of state under Trump. And he
doesn't really have the charisma, the political
abilities, the past successes in my mind,
to really launch him into such a prominent place
in the minds of the Republican base to defeat
Trump or to Santos just doesn't seem likely. But
one of the things I've been thinking about lately.
Would it be better for Trump to be up against a
bunch of people? Mike Pence jumps in the race,
Mike Pompeo jumps in the race.
Some other mike jumps in the race.
We saw John Bolton jumping in the race. DeSantis
And does that do more damage? Even when we know a
lot of those people have no chance of winning?
Or is it better for just to be the Sanders for
Trump and the really tear each other apart?
Let me know what you think in the comments.
If you're watching this on YouTube, definitely
going to be an interesting next two years.